managing director I wonder if you
remember back in Washington uh saying to
the chancellor on the economic forecasts
I hope you prove us wrong well it looks
like maybe he did preview wrong I just
wonder how how important is it how big
of a deal is it if the IMF does keep
getting things wrong does that damage
your reputation do you think and what do
you say to people here who who who are
saying why should we pay any attention
to the IMF this time around
well thank you for your questions so let
me let me say two things one that when
you take a good look at the projections
done by Bank of England consensus
projections and the IMF we are actually
slightly less pessimistic than others
have been to
we have gone through a very turbulent
time over the last years we have
experienced shock upon shock upon shock
and that has created exceptional
uncertainty I I actually think that uh
our staff my colleagues deserve credit
for being agile in how we look at
changing conditions and being fast
to adjust projections so we can give as
clear a picture as we can at the time
that you would agree is the focus we
have seen in many decades